a big chunk of the sky and if you look  at it long enough what you'll see is if  you get lucky what you'll see is when  the planet goes in front of the star  it'll block a little bit of the light  now when I say a little bit I really do  mean a little bit for something like  Jupiter it can block as much as 1% of  the light and that's not very much so so  we see the star dim but just a little  bit but for something like the size of  the earth a planet the size of the earth  it's blocking one ten-thousandth of the  light and that's a very tiny little dip  and so bill Bergey said to himself hey  you know it is a tiny dip but if we've  got really good measuring devices we  call them photometers because they  measure they measure light photo meters  photometers if we've got really good  measuring devices we can see those teeny  little dips and we can actually detect  earth-like planets around other stars  earth size sorry